- [Voiceover] Let's say
we have a linear equation
and we know when X is equal to four
that Y is equal to nine
and we've plotted that
point here on our XY plane.
Actually, I forgot to label
the x-axis right over there.
Now let's say we also know,
we also know that when X is equal to six
Y is equal to one.
And we've plotted that point there.
And so this green line
represents all of the solutions
to this linear equation.
Now what I want to do in this video is
I want to say, well can we
find that linear equation
and can we express it
in both point-slope form
and in slope-intercept form.
And I encourage you, like always,
pause the video and see if you can do it.
So let's first think
about point-slope form.
Point,
point-slope form.
And point-slope form is
very easy to generate
if you know a point on the line,
or if you know a point that satisfies,
where the X and Y coordinates
satisfy the linear equation,
and if you were to know
the slope of the line
that represents the solution
set of that linear equation.
Now for sure we actually
were given two points
that are solutions, that represent
solutions to the linear equation.
To fully apply point-slope, or
to apply point-slope easily,
we just have to figure out the slope.
And what we could do is,
we could just evaluate
well what's the slope between
the two points that we know?
And we just have to remind
ourselves that slope,
slope, is equal to,
slope is equal to change
in y over change in x.
Sometimes people say rise over run.
And what's that going to be?
Well, if we say that this
second point right over here,
if we say this is kind of our,
if we're starting at this
point and we go to that point,
then our change in Y, going
from this point to that point
is going to be,
it's going to be equal to one minus,
one minus nine.
One minus nine.
This point right over here
is the point six comma one.
So we started at Y equals nine,
we finish at Y equals one,
our change in Y is going
to be one minus nine.
We have a negative eight change in Y,
which makes sense.
We've gone down eight.
So this is going to be equal to,
this is going to be
equal to negative eight.
That's our change in Y.
And what's our change in X?
Well we go from X equals
four to X equals six.
So we end up at X equals six
and we started at X equals four.
We started at X equals four,
so our change in X is six minus four,
which is equal to two.
Which is equal to two.
And you could have even done it visually.
To go from this point to
this point your change in Y,
your change in Y is
you went down eight.
So your change in, let me write this.
So your change in Y is
equal to negative eight.
And what was your change in X?
Again to get to this point?
Well, your change in X is positive two.
So your change in X is equal to two.
And so what's your slope?
Change in Y over change in X.
Negative eight over two
is equal to negative four.
So now that we have a,
now that we know the slope
and we know a point, we know a,
we actually know two points on the line,
we can express this in point-slope form.
And so let's do that.
And the way I like to
it is I always like to
just take it straight from the
definition of what slope is.
We know that the slope between
any two points on this line
is going to be negative four.
So if we take an arbitrary
Y that sits on this line
and if we find the difference
between that Y and,
let's focus on this point up here.
So if we find the difference between
that Y and this Y, and nine,
and it's over the difference between
some X on the line and this X, and four.
This is going to be the slope
between any XY on this line
and this point right over here.
And the slope between
any two points on a line
are going to have to be constant.
So this is going to be equal
to the slope of the line.
It's going to be equal to negative four.
And we're not in point-slope form
or classic point-slope form just yet.
To do that, we just multiply
both sides times X minus four.
So we get Y minus 9,
we get Y minus nine is equal to
our slope, negative four
times X minus four.
Time X minus four.
And this right over here is our classic,
this right over here is our
classic point-slope form.
We have the point,
sometimes they even put
parenthesis like this,
but we could figure out the point
from this point-slope form.
The point that sits on
this line with things
that make both sides of
this equation equal to zero.
So it would be X equals
four, Y equals nine,
which we have right up there,
and then the slope is right over here,
it's negative four.
Now from this can we now express this
linear equation in y-intercept form?
And y-intercept form, just
as a bit of a reminder,
it's Y is equal to MX plus B.
Where this coefficient is our slope
and this constant right over here
allows us to figure out our y-intercept.
And to get this in this
form we just have to
simplify a little bit of this algebra.
So you have Y minus nine.
Y minus nine is equal to,
well let's distribute this negative four.
And I'll just switch some colors.
Let's distribute this negative four.
Negative four times X is negative four X.
Negative four time
negative four is plus 16.
And now, if we just want to isolate
the Y on the left hand side,
we can add nine to both sides.
So let's do that.
Let's add nine,
let's add nine to both sides.
Let's add nine to both sides.
On the left-hand side
we're just left with Y.
And on the right-hand side we're left with
negative four X and then
16 plus nine is plus 25.
And there you have it.
We have the same linear
equation, but it's now
represented in slope-intercept form.
Once again, we see the
slope right over here
and now we can figure out
what the y-intercept is.
The y-intercept when X is equal to zero,
Y is going to be equal to 25.
My axis right here, I
haven't drawn it high enough,
but if I made it even taller
and taller and you see
this line is gonna intersect the y-axis
when Y is equal to,
Y is equal to 25.
So there you go, we wrote
it in point-slope form,
that is that right over there,
and we wrote it in Y,
sorry, we wrote it in slope,
we wrote it in slope-intercept form.
Point-slope and slope-intercept.
Hopefully you enjoyed that.